voilà nous recevrons maintenant donc
géniale idée je disais tout à l'heure
l'acteur parce que vous le savez depuis
quelques années il s'est orienté un peu
plus vers le métier de la de la comédie
je vais vous situer le film pour lequel
nous recevons johnny hallyday ça
s'appelle terminus je vous le situe pour
savoir de quoi nous parlons lui et moi
tout à l'heure lors ça se passe dans le
futur on va dire un futur assez proche
il s'agit d'un rallye comme le
paris-dakar mais en plus et il y a des
règles du football américain c'est à
dire qu'on empêche l'adversaire de
progresser il y accuse qui est une jeune
femme qui pilote un camion équipé d'un
ordinateur
elle passera le relais au cours d'un
certain nombre de péripéties à man show
c'est johnny hallyday et tout ça pour
atteindre terminus qui est une base
située en plein désert voilà en gros
n'est ce pas l'action de ce film johnny
hallyday vous disiez tout à l'heure que
c'est un film de science fiction on peut
vraiment le danger surtout avant tout un
film d'aventurés en aventures alors il
peut
je crois que c'est le premier film dans
ce genre en france que con qu'on fait en
france avec des des moyens techniques
comme nous avons eu alors évidemment on
peut reprocher plusieurs sauts chose à
ce fils par exemple notamment sur
peut-être les les dialogues et qui sont
qui pourrait être un peu primaire mais
enfin ce ne faisons ne s'est pas un film
c'est pas du pagnol with fire si vous
regardez non si vous regardez des films
comme rambo ou si vous regardez si vous
allez voir des films comme requis ou les
à moitié les abattoirs et de l'arche
perdue c'est sans nous que vous ne les
fait pas parler comme dans pagnol je
veux dire ce sens dès d'abord moi je
joue le rôle d'un camionneur et j'ai des
dialogues de deux camionneurs je vous
parlait peu mais vous agissez beaucoup
assez type même du film davantage
je pense que je prends quand même pas
mal je parle surtout avec l'ordinateur
ah bah oui oui c'est ça que je voulais
en venir à un ordinateur pour
l'ordinateur il a des il a des
sentiments humains ce qui fait que comme
c'est dans le cadre d'une course il ya
les ya les méchants c'est comme dans un
vestiaire ya les bons et les méchants il
ya les méchants qui sont les grilles qui
tendent des embuscades l'ordinateur se
fâche avec moi donc il se met
volontairement en panne ce qui fait que
ça nous met dans des situations
terrifiantes
bon alors en un extrait précisément de
terminus et puis nous verrons après tout
à l'heure comment s'oriente votre
carrière maintenant alors là johnny
c'est à dire man show dans le film est
évanouie
et puis vous allez voir comment comment
ils sont cent à l'extrait de terminus
qui sort mercredi
entre la brûlure et la lumière choisi la
lumière
oh [ __ ] la vache non monstre mes amis
m'appellent monstre je t'attends des
pilotes mais je suis pas pilote j'ai
compris que du c'était note
non mais c'est tout comme alors
maintenant le pilote sétois népal filer
une manoeuvre de sortie raisonnable de
bush et très stylisé il faut savoir s'il
ya de très beaux éclairages dans ce film
c'est que le réalisateur s'appelle
pierre william glenn et qu'il a été
pendant longtemps directeur de la photo
oui de bertrand tavernier et auprès de
tous les plus grands metteurs en scène
français
alors j'ai vu que dans les gazettes
quand on parle de ce film que ça
correspondait plus ou moins pour vous un
changement de manière de vivre
comment vous dire on vous trouve
maintenant plus ça je dirais plus papa
où vous vous sentez comme ça pourquoi
parce que j'aime mes enfants n'ont pas
du tout non parce que je sais pas où
vous avez expliqué que vous aviez une
vie plus raisonnable c'est à dire que le
meetic le métier d'acteur au cinéma
implique quand même eu dix ont eu une
vie plus régulière quand on tourne un
film il faut se lever très souvent à 5
heures du matin pour être prêt à tourner
à 8h souvent le tournant assez loin le
tournant l'extérieur
donc c'est évident que par rapport à la
à la vie de tous les jours d'un chanteur
nous travaillons soir quand on entre sur
scène donc d'oublier ou un petit peu
c'est un petit peu différent comme
horaire d'accord mais quand j'ai vu
aussi vous étiez le champion du jus de
légumes carottes tomates alors ça que
j'aime bien les jeux début comment vous
croyez que les que les amateurs de rock
vont prendre ça quand ils vont lire
johnny maintenant et il aime le jus de
carottes et les fromages j'adore les
concilier j'adore les jus de carottes et
les jets de tomates mélanger mélanger
avec le jus de série mais ça ne
m'empêche pas d'aimer le bon vin quand
je suis à table au cours d'un reportage
mais ça veut pas dire que dans tous les
concerts de rock maintenant on va se
mettre au jus de tomate
non non non parce que je me dis qu ils
font comment ils vont prendre savez nous
on a à faire on a quand même à faire une
clientèle de gens assez jeune rien et
puis les gens la plupart des gens qui
viennent nous voir sont pas des gens qui
boivent obligatoirement de l'alcool ce
feuillage pas forcément des ivrognes
très bien mon vin kouté merci de nous
avoir rendu visite
terminus c'est mercredi sur les grands
écrans à bientôt merci de m'avoir reçues
il y à des spectacles d'origine
française